who bit Beyonce we are taking a bite out
of the biggest whodunit in modern
history hey guys I'm back hope you
missed me but I got to think ash across
in aka the jail I took my Kimmel for
filling in for me yesterday but you know
what let's not waste any more time
because while I was on vacation
people out here biting Beyonce you can
imagine my horror sitting there at the
airport like it's simple people don't
touch the artwork touching harms the art
and now the biggest witch hunt begins
hence my wand who bit her it is the
biggest unsolved mystery since Solange
beat jay-z in an elevator but I am on
the case and here's what we know about
bike gate Tiffany Haddish is the
whistleblower who sent the internet into
meltdown after she claimed an unnamed
actress went snacking on beast face out
of jay-z concert after-party in December
now it's the latest plot twist and
Tiffany's ongoing word vomit about the
night she met Beyonce and there was
another actress that
she she touches these chests and Beyonce
came walking up glide but her demeanor
her body funny when she walked up on it
was like well the girls trip start
stirred up a hornet's nest in the
Beehive spawning a hashtag after telling
GQ that same actress then bit Beyonce in
the face well Tiffany took to Instagram
today telling Beyonce's loyal legion
y'all forgot I am in the hive too and
just know this I will always speak my
truth that's not going to stop the queen
bee kept me from doing something half of
you bees would have done no matter what
and you know what she's not wrong
Tiffany of course is talking about what
we heard before that she almost beat
said actress at the party or as she told
GQ to quote Beyonce's at the bar so I
said to Beyonce did she really bite you
she was like yeah I was like she gonna
get her ass beat tonight okay so get
this Chrissy Teigen is the informant in
this whole thing but even she won't
crack so crazy it really was a byte
battery there was a fire you can confirm
the bite yes okay so why the bite
happened yes why would anyone bite
listen I think we've all done things
under the info that it was not who
someone who we might expect it was a
surprised person yeah it's not it's not
who I thought I will say but I love the
problem is I love everybody involved so
I'm like you know what's so funny it's
just like if I had a dollar for every
time that I had a few glasses of wine or
something and did some head raise
they've done something like that so
you've wanted to bite people on occasion
I absolutely have done things I asked
John yesterday I was like it's not me is
it so who are the suspects Rihanna
Queen Latifah Sara Foster and Sanaa
Lathan they were all present at the
party but listen to their denials from
Sara Foster flattering that anyone
thinks I could get this close to Beyonce
from Sanaa Lathan under nose
circumstances did I bite Beyonce and if
I did it would have been a love bite
okay and somehow Jayla got thrown into
the mix but guys Jennifer was in New
York City so that leaves Queen Latifah
and Rihanna now I wouldn't put it past
RiRi to get a little too turnt up and
plus she does have a relationship with B
and maybe she thought they had it like
that but I gotta say I don't see Tiffany
or Beyonce ruffling her feathers and
trying to go toe-to-toe with a gallery
in the ring that doesn't make much sense
but could this be a clue model slash
Baywatch actress Charlotte McKinney
attended jay-z's concert and her fellow
model Chrissy Teigen is being super
protective well a rep for McKinney says
she didn't even attend the after-party
so color me confused job will bike gate
ever be solved queen bee's rep won't
comment and Tiffany thank you so the
person who bit Beyonce was now white
cause he nope she's not budging and
let's not forget her initial claim
seemed to inspire that beyonce scolding
and top off so we may never know I mean
this bracket is the only madness this
March if you have any clues or theories
please leave them in the comments for
detective direct oh oh gotta take a
breath after that one y'all while we try
to uncover the identity of Beyonce's
biter we do have a first look at what
just might be one of B's tour looks et
got a special invite to celebrity
designer mark zoom Nino's Beverly Hills
are tilly a where we discovered one
bodice that literally have Beyonce's
name all over it let's talk about
somebody who came to recently I won Miss
Beyonce this is actually a jumpsuit
you're making for the Queen yeah I have
three jumpsuits and some personal expose
that I'm making and
she's wonderful so what are you making
here tell me about this is a jumpsuit
but again it's structured it's all boned
it's structured it's cut down and that's
what everything of course he's saying so
that's what everybody likes is the fact
that they can move and dance it's not
going anywhere
and what is this for wouldn't you ask
this for this jumpsuit one she just was
ordering some show thanks I don't know
where we'll end up show or whatever mark
she is on the run tour comin I think I
you know it's funny because I'm always
anxious to see like everybody else you
know where's it gonna pop up so Wow and
so when you're working with her now
knowing her so well how involved is she
and what is what do you know that
Beyonce wants that she's very definite
she's quick and she's definite so um and
that's what's kind of wonderful she you
know she's yet again she where anything
so it makes it really easy how much does
something like this jumpsuit cost oh
look at what the foundation like this
we're like these are like like usually
like 18 $20,000 yeah we'll see when
Beyonce hits the stage opening night of
on the run to until then we've got
Coachella to look forward to and yep I'm
going both weekend it's not only to
bring you guys to the festival to make
sure no one bites her I got a couple
days of my vegan diet by the way so he
ready and before you go beehive make
sure to share this video because we've
got a case the song
you